In Isesaki, it is another blazing hot day.
At 11 A.M.,...
...the temperature is already somewhere north of 40 degrees Celsius.
For Masaya Maruyama, his wife and brother,...
...working outside in these conditions isn't just hard, it's dangerous.
Masaya shows me the electric fans in his jacket...
...designed to keep him cool,...
...but they hardly seem up to the task.
It went up to 47 degrees on the car's thermometer yesterday, he tells me.
Is it dangerous? I ask.
Yes, it's dangerous.
We've never had temperatures like this before in June.
Usually, it's raining now.
A week ago, most people had never heard of the little city of Isesaki,...
...100 kilometers north of Tokyo.
Now, it's suddenly famous.
This is now officially the hottest place in Japan.
It's been above 40 degrees twice already this week,...
...and according to my thermometer,...
...it's well above that out here in the sunshine today.
This has never happened before in June anywhere in Japan.
This should be the middle of the rainy season...
...and it's causing huge problems for Japan's electricity generating system.
It's just barely keeping up with demand,...
...and if it fails, people are going to die.
These heat waves are not just a natural fluctuation in weather.
Man-made climate change is making them more extreme and more dangerous.